la valise en carton sa mère mais non ici
c'est sa mère linda de suza et la mère
de ne-yo vous saviez pas qu'est ce que
c'est que ce truc va reprendre le
spectacle de sa mère la valise en carton
où j'aimerais le voir
vous assistez les parties gay elle est
chanteuse portugaise je suis portugaise
alors vous avez un traitement quelque
chose streit mon consentement
dépilatoire sa mère qu'elle sa mère de
l'enseignant pas donna summer
sa mère raconte hospital de savères la
valise en carton visant à le voir
vu que c'est une portugaise doit avoir
du poil aux pattes c'est très bien géré
la voir parce que moi aussi j'en ai voir
mais là j'en et puis parce que je suis
pile et vous adorez sa mère linda de
suza maigri de 5 kg une journée à l'on
sache bien ça y est absolument ras ou
les oies et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux